allah et judy alors connaît l'émission
mais julie je vous explique en fait jean
luc lemoine prend tout ce qui se passe
en off dont l'émission tout ce qui est
tourné pendant la pub tout ce que les
téléspectateurs ne voit pas et même là
des choses qui voit mais lui vaut encore
plus que nous et ils dissèquent tout ça
vous allez voir très souvent il ya des
tensions à cause de ça je serai le vrai
visage des personnes autour de cette
table à l'émission une question bonjour
je m'appelle marie-odile j'aime beaucoup
quand vos chroniqueurs dit ce qu'il
pense mais je les aime encore plus quand
ils ferment leur gueule
est-ce qu'elle pourrait le faire plus
souvent
vous ne croyez pas si bien dire car
marie odile car à être chroniqueur c'est
aussi savoir se taire pour laisser la
parole à cyril qui a toujours quelque
chose d'intéressant à dire si toujours
comme ici saisi copté azizi cordes terre
car c'est ça la france
ça c'est la france un seul ça c'est la
france qui danse c'est ce que je vous
dis merci de nous éclairer de nous
montrer la lumière n'ont plus la main
silence mesrine nous le dit souvent
attention les chéris qu'on pourrait
traduire approximativement par fermez
vos gueules vous faites chier et donc
nous avons tous appris à participer à
cette émission sans rien dire le plus
fort dans l'exercice
ah c'est jean michel maire qui se fait
une émission parallèle dans sa tête ça
ça parte un score exceptionnel
on va pas se mentir j'étais un petit peu
déçu sur ce que je coure muriel robin
est très présente et bien sûr
non
quel malade c'est bien c'est ce qu'on
appelle le jeu s'emballe on le sait ça
le jeu sans ballon tu dis rien mais tu
es là c'est ça je pensais que c'était
jean-michel le plus fort dans l'exercice
et finalement j'ai trouvé mieux
quelqu'un qui réussit à faire passer
toutes les émotions sans dire un seul
mot
d'après vous de qui s'agit-il
la belgique est évidemment quelques à
l'aise avec son corps et plus expressifs
de tous
isabelle morini bosc oui attention voilà
elle a regardé la prestation de jimmy
foxtrot vous c'est des voix elle l'a
vécu à fond
je suis demandé des explications sur la
dame mais c'est super en fait j'avais
déjà vu non je ne pensais pas que
c'était cette émission là je pensais que
vous étiez regard des bons sexy mais
voilà ça c'est une bonne chroniqueuse
très présente mais pas envahissante
c'est très difficile qu'aux métiers
chroniqueur de bien appréhender la
fonction une des dernières arrivées dans
l'équipe c'est annie lemoine à annie
lemoine qui s'est très vite intégré
regardez là lors d'une de ses premières
émissions pendant la pub une femme
épanouie on se demande à quoi il pouvait
penser
sa destinat alors je l'aï beaucoup
voulaient pas regarder patrick ou quad
sébastien suis au top non mekhissi se
passer je sais pas je n'ai pas j'ai
coupé sa durée 45 secondes
je vous rassure depuis ça s'arrange et
elle est bien dans l'ambiance maintenant
c'est même la seule de toute l'équipe
capable de chanter notre générique lent
là on sait pas si elle chante aussi on
lui pique sa bagnole mais c'est bien on
n'a jamais vu comme ça non mais c'est
bien ils sont côte à côte
il faut que ça va mieux - trop grand
truc c'est les paroles de chansons elle
est incollable
allez au hasard une autre le bal masqué
à
devrait pas critiquer mais ils sont pas
faits chez pour les paroles la compagnie
vous aurez remarqué qu'à côté comme ya
toujours à fond isabelle hains encore
possédé par le démon de la danse pour
les paisibles mais j'adore un pur
plaisir je les fais une nouvelle compil
voulait jouer la montre et je parle dans
la copie alors d'abord je veux qu
isabelle se cramponne bien parce que
quand elle rigole elle perd tout
contrôle
regardez-la la semaine dernière elle
adore la série on a failli le père de
culbuto ah oui alors ça va très bien
quelle est la whey alors tout de suite
les nouvelles danses bien normal je
t'aime bien et c'est pour ça je te rends
hommage à la créativité
les nouvelles danses 10 heures
hélas
octobre marque
ben hammam à la française qu'on a mêlé
mythes et noisy
oui
alors est ce que j'ai à dire
après j'ai dit je t'aime c'est vrai du
tout
benny dagan barroso nous
mais ce n'est pas la seule un autre
jeudi la création c'est bien évidemment
cyril qui est toujours en ébullition
dans le métier on l'appelle le geyser
c'est plus fort que lui même quand il ne
veut pas il invente un jeu un mot assure
non tout de suite une nouvelle
démonstration un îlot il nous reste
os x et gamma peut-être arrêter la tête
de perdre deux fois et nous restons à
l'écouté
l'avenir de la télévision française oui
il a eu tout à la fin
alors pour être complètement honnête je
vais vous passez un extrait qui n'est
pas drôle et qui prouve que quand ils
dépassent les bornes screens et demandé
pardon excusez moi je deviens
complètement fou et doha enora ce toit
la foule
et ben non finalement il avait pas honte
alors non mais cyril il assume tout même
sa passion pour britney spears
il faut le savoir cyril m2 chose dans la
vie britney et aider les gens le
problème c'est qu'il veut tout faire en
même temps
là il va aider notre dame de ménage
enfin je ne sais pas si ça va vraiment
aider
obeid a je donne de la cheminée à des
moines et je tiens mes bébés malades
skis
nda hamas comme terre
dimanche m
- mahmud aux mamans la connais par coeur
mais c'est ça alors je précise 1 c'était
pour rire tout ça rit non parce qu'avec
le climat autour de vous je pense que
sans précision demain on va voir ce
genre d'article sur internet
scandale à tpm paix abusant de sa
position dominante s'il y en a un seul
technicien de son climat chaud là vous
aurez tous vos niveaux la taxe
d'habitation
ce procès est plié ok donc pas ce que ça
peut sortir ça non je préfère me back et
non la semaine dernière autre moment
marquant nous recevions clara morgane
pour le ishow qui était aussi l'objet
depuis hier à la télé alors je vais vous
passez en extraits du débat car si clara
n'était pas là son micro était déjà
installé quand enora c'est lisa parler
d'elle à or bien oui d'idées et dont
elle avait dit qu'elle était divine sur
les patins comment a réagi clara la
réponse tout de suite fait on va tout et
en os mais tu va patiner dans les airs
ce que malheureusement clara la tête
pratique ça parce que moi je les
trouvais absolument divine mais elle
était en l'air sur terre
donc on a fallu une tête sauvée
d'honneur bien joli ab
avec laval s'est assise près de
jean-michel jean-michel à côté de clara
morgane c'est comme si tu en deviens un
gamin disneyland paris il avait essayé
en plusieurs étapes d'abord la classe
sans rien dire c'est d'enlever la main
quand même un voyage émouvant
j'aime pas trop con ah oui c'est vrai
j'aime bien ça après après il ya eu le
jeu du calais la question doit bien sûr
un buzzer bizarrement sur quelles mains
jean-michel va-t-il poser la sienne
vous vous demandez de tous fait remettre
votre main sur le buzzer touchez vous
aimez vous la france
à saissac la france d'aujourd'hui c'est
six mois
et là bien en place et le buzzer le
gardien qui inquiète sable et de kem
sokha contre enquête
il était content le lourdaud et non il
peut pas s'en empêcher jean michel alors
pour finir je vous les montre à l'entrée
de clara où elle a eu le malheur de
poser sa main sur les épaules de jean
michel aulas mais ça va il a géré
jeudi
ap la discorde dans le gers